ab donnerstag gelten in münchen
knallhart knallharte corona regeln der
grund dafür sind die steigenden
infektionszahlen in münchen
konkret heißt das es soll eine massen
pflicht auf bestimmten öffentlichen
plätzen geben auf dem marienplatz zum
beispiel und auch den viktualienmarkt
muss man dann auch draußen eine maske
tragen
außerdem dürfen sich nur noch fünf
personen treffen oder zwei haushalte und
auch bei den privaten feiern wurden die
regeln verschärft dort dürfen sich dann
nur noch in geschlossenen räumen 25
menschen versammeln und im freien
maximal 50 diese regeln sollen dann erst
mal für sieben tage gelten
thomas cook ist für uns in münchen genau
auf dem marienplatz wo dann also ab
donnerstag dieser masken schlecht gelten
wird und er hat gäste bei sich die einen
sind für diese masken pflegt die anderen
dagegen sehr sonnigen warmen marienplatz
alles voller touristen und münchner die
ab donnerstag alle hier nur noch mit
maske flanieren und shoppen dürfen
münchen muss in die maske das wird
natürlich in der stadt heiß und
kontrovers diskutiert und wir haben
heute wie du schon sagtest zwei menschen
hier die mit uns darüber sprechen wollen
zunächst einmal haben wir elke fett
stand besitzerin vom viktualienmarkt
frau fällt vielen dank dass sie da sind
und gastronom stefan adorf der sich für
die masten pflicht ausspricht verlauf ab
donnerstag dürfen wir hier eigentlich
nur noch mit maske stehen gehen sitzen
sie sind dafür warum naja erstmal muss
ich sagen glaubt irgendein mensch dass
das teil tragen dieser maske freude
bereitet natürlich nicht aber wir wissen
und ich finde wir sind immer noch am
anfang der pandemie der wissen dass sie
schützt und ich möchte nicht die
diskussion führen
erstens möchte ich mein gegenüber möchte
ich sie schützen zum beispiel und ich
möchte nicht die diskussion führen ob
das kind mit einem jahr oder die person
mit 95 jahre lebenswert ist da gibt es
keinen unterschied deshalb genau deshalb
trage ich gerne diese maske um menschen
zu schützen
dies ist denn auch so wenn sie privat
durch die stadt gehen und sie merken da
ist eine straße voller leute setzen sie
dann
schon auch aus vorsicht eine maske auf
also ich bin keiner der der panik
verbreitet aber ich bin am samstag vom
sendlinger tor in die sendlinger straße
eingebogen und habe sehr viele menschen
gesehen also zu viele menschen für mich
dann habe ich halt einfach habe ich dann
okay das kann es doch ein andermal
einkaufen bin umgetreten gegangen aber
ja wenn ich merke das ist unangenehm und
die leute kommen wir zu einer trage ich
die maske ganz klar dank robert sie sind
händlerin auf dem viktualienmarkt und
haben es jetzt in dieser kroner zeit
natürlich sehr schwer auch als händlerin
ist das ein grund auch warum sie wie
masken pflicht in der öffentlichkeit
ablehnen also ich lehne grundsätzlich ab
solange man an der frischen luft ist und
den mindestabstand einhalten kann da
finde ich ist man gesundheitlich auf
jeden fall besser dran als mit einer
maske die zehn mal auf und runter
gezogen wird und eigentlich für mich
sinnlos erscheint und genau das ist für
mich der punkt dass man eigentlich
darauf schaut wenn man mir verordnung
macht dass man diese verordnung dann
auch ein held weil was bei uns am
letzten samstag am viktualienmarkt los
war und die verwaltung das scheinbar gar
nicht mitbekommen hat das tut mir
richtig weh man muss verordnungen machen
und die versuchen dann auch zu
einzuhalten sie können mir nicht sagen
dass am marienplatz die maske sinn macht
wenn man um die ecke rum in der
dienerstraße schon nicht mehr muss das
leuchtet mir nicht ein was es gab ja
letzten samstag sehr große
menschenansammlungen auf dem
viktualienmarkt die leute haben
oktoberfest privat gefeiert was hätte
was könnte die stadt sonst ihrer meinung
nach tun um solche menschenansammlungen
zu verhindern ohne masken berichten es
ging nicht um die menschenansammlungen
wenn die iren mindestabstand einhalten
so wie wir hier auch in dieser runde
stehen habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen
und wir alle auf markt auch nicht nur
wir händler
wir haben ja jetzt bewiesen wie schön
das einkaufen im freien ist und auch
ohne maske solange wir die
freiwilligkeit haben ziehen die leute
auch mit aber sie glauben doch wohl
nicht dass junge leute sich zwingen
lassen die werden das jetzt erst recht
machen und da bin ich überzeugt davon
damit werden wir nichts erreichen so
vielen dank auf etlichen lang wir haben
auch jemand aus der politik wir haben
münchens dritte bürgermeisterin verena
titel von der spd-frau dietl kontakt
beschränkungen kleinere
geburtstagsfeiern kleinere hochzeiten
masken pflicht auf der straße warum hat
die stadt menschen solche starken
einschränkungen gestern erlassen ja es
ist ja bekannt die sieben tage incidents
ist immer mehr angestiegen über 50 und
stabil geblieben und wir müssen einfach
drastische maßnahmen danach ergreifen
werden gerade am wochenende gesehen dass
die menschen eben keinen abstand
gehalten haben dass sie sich miteinander
getroffen haben und wir müssen schon
dann auch diese dynamik irgendwie
unterbinden und die einzige möglichkeit
dies braucht sind dann einfach maßnahmen
zu ergreifen
wir haben jetzt versucht software
maßnahmen zu ermöglichen also wirklich
hier in der fußgängerzone und am
viktualienmarkt die massen pflicht
einzuführen
es ist ja auch nicht für das ganze
stadtgebiet und es ist schon so wenn der
wert bleibt oder noch einmal ansteigen
müssen wir auch zu anderen maßnahmen
greifen und in der abwägung ist es mir
wichtiger dass wir den kosten
für kinder und jugendliche die kinder in
tageseinrichtungen und die schulen offen
lassen und das wirkt den gastronomen
gastronomie nicht einschränken müssen
das war mir jetzt wichtiger bei der
entscheidung und wenn manche ein
bisschen vernünftiger sich verhalten
würden dann werden diese maßnahmen
vielleicht auch nicht notwendig gewesen
die nachfrage ist ja schon die
intensivstation sie nicht voll
der letzte todesfall ist gott sei dank
von ende auch von anfang august die
menschen in münchen scheinen ja diese
steigenden infektionszahlen ja auch
gegen die gesundheitlich zu verkraften
warum muss man jetzt schon so hart
dazwischen grätschen
wir wollen auf keinen fall dass der wert
zusätzlich gesteigert wird und es gibt
menschen die einfach risikopatienten
sind und die dann auch gefährdet sind
und wenn der wert immer mehr steigt und
die infektionsgeschehen immer mehr
zunimmt dann sind die menschen wieder
gefährdet ich bin auch für die
pflegeheime zuständig wir möchten auf
keinen fall dass dort wieder fälle
auftreten und dann wird es nämlich
wieder drastischer werden deswegen muss
man lieber früher die reißleine ziehen
und da auch was machen
münchen steht vor seiner ersten großen
massen pflicht in der öffentlichkeit man
kann nur hoffen dass diese maßnahme
wirkt und dass das die letzte
einschränkungen die menschen in diesem
herbst dank zu erleiden hatte mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren